O On poursuit sur ce sujet
avavec Jean Lapointe, expert
enen aviation civile et ex-pilo.
C C'est un bon début, ces amens
popour six des passagers?
VoVous espérez que d'autres
leleur soient imposées?
- - Tout à fait. Avec les vidéos
ququ'on a pu voir qui ont été
plplacé par eux-mêmes sur les
mémédias se, on voit qu'il y a s
cocomportements beaucoup plus
dadangereux que de ne pas avoir
apapporté ou d'avoir triché le
papasseport maximal à propos dea
COCOVID. Lorsqu'on amène sa proe
boboisson ou qu'on fume dadans n
avavion et qu'on ne suit pas les
coconsignes qui sont demandées r
leles agents de bord, on met la
sésécurité des passagers et des
memembres de l'équipage en dang.
OuOui, on espère qu'il y aura
d'd'autres amendes.
- - Vous dénoncez ce convoi,
dadanser, être debout sur un sie
etet fumée. Pourquoi c'est
dadangereux de boire ou de vapor
dadans un avion?
- - Il faut savoir dans un premr
tetemps qu'à prendre une
coconsommation à bord d'un avion
ququi voilà 35 000 pieds, c'est
sosouvent un équivalent de deux
veverres de boissons prises au l
dodonc on s'intoxiquait beaucoup
plplus rapidement et c'est poura
ququ'on demande aux passagers de
nene pas apporter leur propre
boboisson pour que les agents de
bobord puissent garder un certan
cocontrôle dans la cabine. Il ft
sasavoir que n'importe quel être
huhumain qui consomme beaucoup à
peperdre ses inhibitions et sa
cacapacité de suivre les
coconsignes. Souvent, par-delà a
cicigarette électronique, on a u
dadans le passé des gens qui
alallaient dans les toilettes qi
s's'allumaient des cigarettes et
c'c'est extrêmement dangereux. n
papassager intoxiqué lors de ma
cacarrière j'en ai vu qui se sot
dédéshabillés dans les avions. s
y y en a qui ont amorcé des
babatailles, ils y en a qui ont
esessayé d'ouvrir des portes des
papassagers ou des sortes de
sésécurité. Alors c'est
exextrêmement dangereux.
- - On peut imaginer. On ne
coconnaît pas le montant exact s
amamendes qui ont été imposées à
seses passagers. On peut se
dedemander : est-ce que l'effet
didissuasif sera suffisant?
- - J'ose espérer qu'il y aura
évéventuellement une liste qui
emempêchera ces gens, ces
dédélinquants pour ne pas avoira
cacapacité de voler sur des
sosociétés aériennes quelles
ququ'elles soient au Canada, des
sosociétés aériennes canadienne,
etet nous sommes très contents s
memembres de l'aviation d'abord
quque les médias font un suivi
cocomme vous faites ce soir pour
quque le grand public soit au
cocourant que le Transport Canaa
frfrançais mauvais geste très au
sésérieux.
- - Vous parlez de cette liste i
n'n'existait pas encore, la lise
ququi interdit à des gens de
momontée à bord d'avion. Mais ls
amamendes qui ont été décernées,
cocommencez reçu? Comment c'est
peperçu par les gens de
l'l'industrie? Est-ce que les
agagents d'abord ce centre assué
ququ'on encadre un peu mieieux s
dédélinquants?
- - Je pense qu'il faut dire das
unun certain sens merci à la
papandémie, parce que nos pauvrs
agagents d'abord, quelles sont
n'n'importent où sur la planète,
avavec l'arrivée du masque pendt
leles vols, ça a été extrêmement
didifficile pour toutes les
sosociétés aériennes et surtout
leles agents débordent à respecr
lele port du masque. Je pense qe
lala pandémie pour la première
fofois a permis aux ministère ds
TrTransports de saisir la
didifficulté qu'ont les agents
dédébordent à respecter les
coconsignes et il semble qu'avec
seses amendes, qu'il y ait un
trtravail qui s'est fait, une
sysynergie derrière les portes
clcloses entre les sociétés
aéaériennes et Transport Canada.
JeJe peux vous dire aujourd'hui
ququ'on espère qu'il n'y en aura
d'd'autres, mais on est très
sasatisfait du travail de
TrTransport Canada à ce moment-.
- - Il y a un transporteur aérin
ququi demande qu'il y ait une
liliste des gens qui ne pourrait
plplus embarquer à bord des
avavions. Est-ce que vous pensez
ququ'on en arrivera là?
- - Chaque société aérienne
d'd'envergure à son propre syste
dede sécurité interne. Si je pee
àà Air Canada par exemple, il ya
dédéjà des passagers qui sont
emempêchés de voler. Ce qu'on st
totout ce que Delta souhaite,
c'c'est que cette liste soit
papartagée entre les différents
trtransporteurs par une agence
cocommune comme Transport Canada
papar exemple. Transport Canada
popourrait éventuellement faire
papartager la liste des gens qui
sosont interdits dans un avion t
quque Air Canada ou WestJet soit
auau courant que quelqu'un est
babanni sur les ailes de Sunwing
papar exemple.
- - Pour que toutes les compagni